Gunshots echo down the concrete hallway of
Site-22.
Screams are the only thing that escape each
room.
A team of men in all black combat gear and
masks move from one section of the complex
to the next.
Pietro Wilson hides in his office, listening
to the cries for mercy of his colleagues.
He shakes uncontrollably with fear.
Who are they? he thinks.
Why are they killing everyone and how did
they find us?
Moments earlier Pietro Wilson had been in
the canteen eating dinner with other staff
members.
A group of heavily armed men entered the room.
They stood silently surveying the area.
One of the scientists stood up and asked if
they could assist them.
That’s when the carnage started.
One of the masked men raised his rifle and
shot the scientists in the head.
Chaos broke out as the other mercenaries raised
their weapons and began firing.
Bullets flew everywhere and Pietro was lucky
not to be struck or trampled as he escaped
out the back door of the cafeteria.
He ran to his office, slammed the door shut,
and hid under his desk.
Now he sits on the floor with his legs pulled
up to his chest shaking uncontrollably.
After a couple of minutes he manages to take
a deep breath and slows his heart rate.
He regains control of his body, but is still
filled with fear and adrenaline.
Pietro crawls on his belly to his office door.
He reaches up and pulls down on the handle.
There is a slight click as the latch releases.
He opens the door just a crack and peers out
into the hallway.
The flickering emergency lights illuminate
the corridor for a few seconds at a time before
plunging it back into darkness.
There is no one in sight, but from around
the corner flashes of light from machine gun
fire flickers down the hall.
The screams of the workers at Site-22 are
silenced.
Pietro takes a deep breath and pushes the
door open further.
He crawls out of his office and starts moving
away from the violence.
Unfortunately, to get away from the mayhem
he must go deeper into the bowels of Site-22.
The exit is the other way, but he is too scared
to head towards the armed men.
He stands up and brushes the dirt from his
blue technician jumpsuit.
The lights flicker off, the hallway goes dark.
He reaches out his hands and comes into contact
with the cool damp wall.
He feels his way down the corridor, swimming
in darkness.
After a few moments the lights flicker back
on.
Pietro looks over his shoulder to make sure
he is still in the clear.
Standing at the end of the hall is a soldier
dressed in all black with a mask covering
his face.
The soldier stands motionless.
Pietro turns to face the soldier, his eyes
open wide, his heart races, he can’t breath.
The figure doesn’t move.
Then the lights flicker out again and Pietro
pushes off the wall and runs, blind in the
darkness.
He sprints as fast as he can when suddenly
there is a loud crack and a bullet whizzes
by his head.
He can feel the wind as it barely misses his
cheek.
He continues to run.
The lights flicker back on, he peers over
his shoulder.
Now there is an entire group of armed men
pursuing him down the hallway, guns raised.
He turns the corner of the hallway and proceeds
down a set of stairs further into Site-22.
At the bottom of the stairway there is a short
corridor with a door at the end of it.
There’s nowhere else to go.
He pulls a key card out of his pocket and
fumbles it.
The card falls to the ground.
Pietro bends down to pick it up and as he
leans over a bullet whizzes past where his
head had just been.
The projectile embeds itself into the metal
door.
He scoops his key card up off the ground and
shoves it against the scanner.
The door unlocks and he dashes into the room.
He quickly turns and shuts the door.
It locks automatically.
The last thing he sees is the assassins running
towards the door.
The lights flicker on in the room where Pietro
stands.
The room has only one door, no windows, and
no vents.
It is completely isolated.
In the middle of the room is SCP-5000.
He knew there was a SCP in this room that
was designated SCP-5000, but he never knew
what it actually was.
Here he is now, staring at it.
A strange looking mechanical harness hanging
in the middle of the room.
Suddenly, loud banging at the door fills the
room.
The armed men are trying to break in.
It is only a matter of time before they pry
the door open.
With nowhere to go Pietro Wilson knows that
he is dead.
He looks at SCP-5000 and shakes his head.
“What do I have to lose?” he says out
loud.
Only your life, a voice inside his head responds.
He walks over to SCP-5000 and pulls it down
from where it's hanging.
It is heavy.
On the mechanical suit are symbols he does
not recognize.
The only things he knows about the suit are
rumors he’s heard from others who work at
Site-22.
Supposedly, it first appeared in a flash of
light in the containment chamber of a Keter
level SCP at Site-62C.
The designation of this Keter was SCP-579.
The only other thing that Pietro knows is
that everyone at Site-62C was slaughtered
when containment was breached.
SCP-5000 was found deactivated next to a pile
of bodies.
He slips on the harness and Ss if it has a
life of its own, SCP-5000 begins to adjust
itself to the exact dimensions of his body.
The suit grows and snakes across his skin,
wrapping every appendage in armor.
Then it begins to tighten.
Pietro Wilson starts to scream as SCP-5000
envelops him.
The suit rises up the back of his neck and
encases his entire head, silencing his screams.
The door to the room blasts open from a controlled
explosion.
As the dust and smoke settles the masked men
enter the room.
Their flashlights move from side to side as
they search for the elusive technician who
had just entered.
There is no one in the room.
All that is there is an empty rack in the
middle of the chamber.
The men fan out, but there is no other exit.
The room is just a solid square of concrete.
They are baffled.
“Where did he go?” one of them shouts.
Pietro Wilson had blacked out from the pain
of the suit attaching to his body.
He comes to still standing in the middle of
the room.
All around him are men in black combat gear.
They are searching for him.
He holds his breath and closes his eyes.
But the gun shots never come.
He opens one of his eyes and looks around.
Why haven’t they killed me yet? he thinks.
He slowly turns his head as men walk by him
with their guns raised.
He hears someone say, “where did he go?”
I’m right here, he thinks.
Am I dead?
Pietro looks down to see that his entire body
is contained within SCP-5000.
He lifts his hand and waves it in front of
his face.
He is still clearly alive, but it seems as
if the killers can’t see him.
He walks up to one of the mercenaries and
waves his hand in front of the man’s face.
There is no reaction.
The suit made me invisible, he thinks.
Pietro looks at one of the men to see if he
can find out who they are and why they have
killed everyone at the base.
On the sleeve of the man’s jacket are the
words Zeta-19.
He’s never heard of Zeta-19 before, but
they must be a part of an organization that
is trying to undermine the SCP Foundation.
The men continue to search the empty room,
clearly confused as to where the technician
went.
Pietro weaves his way through the group of
men and back out the door he had entered from.
On his way through the wreckage that used
to be a door, Pietro Wilson trips on some
debris.
He reaches out to steady himself, but he is
falling.
He closes his eyes knowing that as soon as
he hits the ground all of the men hunting
him will be alerted by the sound of his fall.
But the impact never comes.
When Pietro opens his eyes it is as if he
is hovering just above the ground.
He looks down at his feet.
The toes of the suit are firmly planted on
the floor like powerful magnets on iron.
SCP-5000 has prevented his fall and is holding
him in place using the feet of the suit only.
He reaches out his hand and gently places
it on the ground.
He pushes himself up to a standing position.
He turns to look back into the room, the men
are still in there searching for him.
Pietro makes his way back through Site-22.
He walks by his office and proceeds towards
the exit of the facility.
As he passes the labs and other rooms at Site-22
all he finds is carnage.
Everyone has been killed.
An extra bullet has been placed in each person’s
head to make sure.
It seems that the only mission these men were
on was to kill everyone, and make sure they
stayed dead.
He continues towards the exit of Site-22 that
is guarded by two men.
As he approaches the two heavily armed men,
Pietro makes sure to be as quiet as possible.
This is not a difficult task as the SCP-5000
has given him stealth capabilities.
He notices that even his footsteps aren’t
giving off any sound.
It is almost as if the suit is allowing him
to glide across the floor.
He is almost to the exit, then he will be
home free.
He takes a deep breath, turns sideways, and
squeezes past the two men guarding the doorway.
Just as he is about to leave this nightmare
behind, one of the guards turns unexpectedly.
The man’s shoulder runs directly into Pietro
Wilson throwing him off balance.
He is knocked into the second guard, both
of the men begin to scream.
“What is that?” one of them shouts.
They begin to raise their guns on the invisible
object that just bumped into them.
It’s then that SCP-5000 takes over Pietro’s
body.
The suit raises his arm and grabs one of the
men by the throat.
With a squeeze the man’s larynx is instantly
crushed.
Then the suit twists slightly and snaps the
man’s neck.
It turns to face the second man.
Even the black mask the man is weaning can’t
hide the look of terror on his face, but Pietro
has no control over what SCP-5000 is doing.
He has never killed before.
The suit launches Pietro’s body into the
second man, pinning him against the wall.
It then grabs the top of the mercenary’s
head and slams it against the concrete again,
and again, and again, until the man’s screams
are silenced.
The suit lets go of the man and his lifeless
body slides to the ground as Pietro blacks
out.
When he regains consciousness, he’s outside
of Site-22 standing on top of a hill, looking
down at the facility below.
He looks at his hands, then at the rest of
his body.
He is still contained within SCP-5000.
There is a flash of light and a heads up display
comes on.
He doesn’t recognize any of the symbols,
but as his eyes move from one area of the
screen to the next, the symbols become highlighted.
Before his eyes certain symbols begin to translate
into words he can read.
One of the symbols now says: Journal Entry.
Unsure of what else to do, Pietro begins recounting
what happened to him at Site-22.
He makes his way through the desert towards
the nearest SCP Foundation safe house.
He knows once there he will be able to reach
out to his superiors for help and further
orders.
Maybe he can even find a way to get SCP-5000
to release him.
As he trudges along, Pietro Wilson notices
that his brain is telling him he is thirsty.
But the vitals on the suit’s heads up display
say he is in good health.
In fact, he is better than good, his vitals
are all perfect.
The suit seems to be giving him all the nutrients
his body needs.
It has even fixed his busted knee that was
injured back in college playing football.
The joint itself has somehow been healed.
Pietro finally reaches the safe house and
opens the door.
It is quiet and dusty.
It looks as if no one has been there in years.
He walks over to the communications station
and tries to contact the Foundation but all
he gets is static.
He gives up and walks over to the TV.
He pushes the on button, the screen hisses
to life.
What he sees causes his jaw to drop.
The world is at war.
A war between humans and monsters.
Whatever happened at Site-22 also happened
at other Foundation sites.
The SCPs have been let loose.